sí Lo cierto es que Turquía Hasta ahora
ha sabido jugar unas cartas en que ha
mantenido un complicado Equilibrio es un
miembro importante de la alianza pero a
la vez es el único Aliado que mantiene
que mantiene la comunicación abierta con
Rusia junto con Hungría de hecho el país
se ha convertido en un mediador en el
caso del acuerdo del grano y de hecho en
reiteradas ocasiones se ha ofrecido como
mediador unas hipotéticas conversaciones
de paz entre Ucrania y Rusia esto Esto
es bastante importante Este viaje de
zelensky a Turquía porque sobre todo lo
que quiere asegurarse es que tiene a
ankara también como un posible Aliado en
esta en esta invitación a que pueda por
formar parte en un futuro de la alianza
zelens que está muy interesado en poder
mantener estos estos canales de
comunicación con Turquía y evitar que se
pueda producir un vete o como el que ha
producido como el que ha tenido con
Finlandia y que aún mantiene con Suecia
Así que zelensky espera que con esta
reunión todas pueda ser mucho más fluido
y al menos contar también con el voto de
Turquía a pesar de sus relaciones con
Rusia